drew barrymore really stepped in it oh
yes she did drew barrymore
beloved
film and tv star very well i don't know
anyone who doesn't like drew barrymore
she just posted a tick tock of herself
frolicking in the rain
and a
black identity activist got very very
upset by it
you and i both know
that you are capable
of enjoying the rain and frolicking
freely without filming it and then
posting it to tick tock
now you've just cosigned
okay you just co-signed at least 3
million 8.5 by 11 front and back people
who just
go out of their way
to disrespect and
dismiss the boundaries that black
creators have set
and now you're one of those people so
i guess my question would be
why
why why is it so important to all of you
to treat us like
we don't matter
yeah drew
yeah drew barrymore
why why did you have to be so mean to
black people by
frolicking in the rain
when i first saw this clip i thought it
had to be satire
maybe it is but i don't think it is
she's
and the woman isn't making any argument
as i was trying i listened to i've
listened to it multiple times now i
don't hear any argument i hear words
that are being said in succession but i
don't see any of them forming a coherent
english sentence and but it she's got
the tone of an argument
be like saying
pineapple microphone
pineapple give it a google d giveaway
google the gobbledy
glass glass wood
up down
green purple
hammer
right it's i've got the tone and the
inflection of an argument but i'm just
saying gibberish that's what that woman
is doing because
it's really representative actually how
the left is conducting politics because
they're not making arguments that that
refer to
the the real meaning of words that use
words in the correct way that's what you
hear when corinne jean-pierre calls
everyone fascists but can't point any
definition of fascism that's what you
see with political correctness when the
word when the libs just change the
meaning of all the words sometimes
multiple times in a single sentence
because it's not about any logical
argument
it's all just about power
that video what that comes down to is
white people bad
black people good
white people do what black people tell
white people to do that's all that
really means if if
you can pretend that frolicking in the
rain is a race issue and that you have
the right because of your race to tell
someone else because of her race not to
frolic in the rain then all you're
saying is you you as a result of your
race need to be subservient to me as a
result of my race that's all that means
it's about power and that's what all of
this is about you're seeing a similar
argument from not just some kukan tiktok
but from some kook running for the
united states senate a uh the democrat
candidate for senate wisconsin jesse
mandela barnes
has just argued that national parks
are you guessed it racist quote
it's important to create more welcoming
spaces because things haven't always
felt welcome and that's historical just
that perspective given the fact that
national parks weren't made for the
enjoyment of people who weren't white
national parks are built on land that
was indigenous
things were bad things were terrible the
founding of this nation awful he says
but you know we are here now and we
should commit ourselves to to do
everything we can to repair the harm
because it still exists and it's it's
colonization and slavery
so there the
the claim he's making is right there in
the middle he says the the founding of
this nation awful
and the proof of this is that racism is
everywhere and you can't see it
it's in the parks okay where is it can
you point to that in history can you
point to that right now in the parks
do they have a whites-only water
fountain in the parks no
but it's race it's it's it's all bad
america's all bad and then the language
we use for bad is race it's the worst
it's it's the worst thing you can
possibly be called in america is racist
so everything has to be tied back to it
even things that have absolutely nothing
to do with race like national parks and
frolicking in the rain but all that that
is about is power and it's power aimed
at a very specific
target namely the traditional american
political order
the founding of this country awful and
it's all awful and the word we're gonna
give to what's awful about it is racism
even though things a lot of these things
have absolutely nothing to do with race
and that's our argument for why
everything needs to be overturned all
the tradition's overturned and anyone
who defends the traditional american
order anyone who waves an american flag
i guess at this point mostly just
republicans
they need to be
exterminated they need to be
attacked in their homes they need to be
pushed back on in public they need to be
kept from from exercising their free
speech rights they need to be kept from
speaking in the public square and voting
they need to be ostracized and sometimes
we need a little violence to be
inflicted on them that is the argument
from the libs right now right now head
on over to goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what joe biden
wants to call a recession americans are
worried food and gas prices are higher
than i've ever seen in my lifetime we're
talking about 40 or high really all-time
highs i guess that's why i'm so very
grateful for my favorite meat delivery
service good ranchers good ranchers
offers an inflation proof subscription
model that lets you lock in the price
the day you subscribe i'm not joking or
exaggerating even with all the crazy
inflation that we're seeing you
subscribe right now you can always buy
good ranchers just a one-off box of meat
but if you subscribe
the price will never go up for the cost
of your
subscription also you can pause your
subscription for up to 90 days cancel
anytime you want but you're not going to
want to not only that good ranchers is
also currently running a back to school
give back program with the goal of
donating 100 000 high quality meals to
children in need
to help them i'm offering 10 lucky
listeners the chance to win 30 minutes
with me via zoom on september 30th we're
calling it a meet and greet do you get
it you can ask me anything on the call
be a lot of fun head on over to
use code knowles at checkout you get 30
bucks off plus free shipping subscribe
to lock in your price recession proof
your meals for life be automatically
entered to win 30 minutes of all access
with me on september 30th that offer
ends august 31st goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles at checkout i'm
so glad you like that clip now you got
to subscribe we i appreciate it i'm glad
we hit a million subscribers i want to
hit one quadrillion ring that bell get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]